[Applause]
[Music]
it took just one week one week was
really all the time that was needed for
this man the President of the United
States dava's first diplomatic crisis so
who was this crisis with well you can
probably get for the answer is Mexico
Mexico Mexico is the new China Mexico is
killing us the country of Mexico is
killing us Donald Trump is well let's
say unique he might be the only head of
state capable of defying in public a
foreign president in this case at pena
nieto by telling him on Twitter he
doesn't travel to Washington with the
idea of paying to the wall he may as
well stay at home needless to say the
visit never happened
lynitra all NATO service Mickey Cook not
like that anyone
but don't worry viewers we've had enough
Trump talk to the Donald is not going to
be the main character in this video
today we're going to focus on the
natural agreement and especially on the
relationship between Mexico and the
United States of America
[Music]
laughter is a free trade agreement
between the US Canada and Mexico it was
negotiated by President George HW Bush
in 1992 and it was ratified and
implemented by Bill Clinton in 1994
[Applause]
which means NAFTA has been supported
both by Democrats and Republicans but
let's take a look back and analyze which
events took place south of the Bravo
River let's travel back in time to the
1980s a time when Mexico was exhausted
the country's economic model was a worn
out closed economy and they were in a
state of crisis in fact it was at that
time that massive emigration from Mexico
to the US started to happen
and it wasn't just any migratory wave it
was one of the biggest migration waves
of all time
and all of this happened in a time when
Americans weren't particularly liked in
Mexico since the war with the u.s. from
1846 to 1847 half of its territory the
popular sentiment in the country was
that the US was a great villain and an
enemy that Mexico was facing by 1988 it
was clear that Mexico's closed system
was worn out and the President of Mexico
who at the time was carlos salinas
Harvard graduate by the way decided to
end this and opted for opening up next
Co to the outside world in his own words
the u.s. is not the worst threat such as
the best opportunity and the leaders in
north america decided they didn't want
to waste this charm they got down to
business and decided to bet on extending
to Mexico a free trade agreement that
they had recently signed with Canada
with this NAFTA was born since then
relations between the US and Mexico have
expanded a great deal it is estimated
the trade between the two countries
today exceeds half a trillion dollars
now half a trillion which is 500 billion
dollars is quite a hard number to get
your head around in more relatable terms
each minute that means more than a
million dollars worth of products
crosses the border of the US and Mexico
[Music]
or to put it in a more international
context trade between the u.s. and
Mexico is the equivalent of the Chilean
economy and is more than the entire
economy of Argentina the current
American president Donald Trump
threatens this Agreement Sanders even
considered putting an end to it because
according to him it is the worst
agreement that the US has ever signed
NAFTA is the worst trade deal maybe ever
signed anywhere but certainly ever
signed in this country now that's just
what he says and the reality well it's
rather different master has in general
being something of a gold mine for the
United States
[Music]
it isn't said but whenever Trump has a
nightmare it's always the same thing he
sees a Mexican stealing his wallet
essays incorporation decided to lower
your company anyway we don't know if
this is true this probably not but it
would explain his obsession with Mexico
and also why whenever he thinks of NAFTA
he thinks of the American people getting
robbed but don't think that it is only
the president who holds in this opinion
many defenders of protectionism in the
US state is that Mexican and Canadian
workers are causing American jobs to
disappear because of free trade
specifically they claim that imports
exceed exports by almost 80 billion
dollars and that's a lot of money but
the reality is that these figures are
about as reliable as a chocolate teapot
first there are two goods that twist
those numbers which have nothing to do
with NASA petrol and natural gas and
this is really important because if we
don't consider those products that Trent
holder Trump is talking about it pretty
much disappears
[Music]
and so now some of you were probably
thinking well Simon why wouldn't you
consider petrol and natural gas and
that's a good question
well that's because unless Trump wants
to take the United States act as a
stone-age he will have to keep getting
all the petrol the country needs whether
that's from Mexico Canada
Saudi Arabia or well anywhere else but
these fudged figures are the only ones
the protectionist dreamers also fudge
the figures for they also do this by not
considering service businesses this
includes things like the financial
sector insurance sector traveling
consulting the internet etc etc etc but
ignoring these things is like saying
that banks don't make money and the
Google simply doesn't exist so if we
adjust these two figures it turns out
that the USAID's result is not a deficit
that's actually a surplus that's true
for both Mexico and well as Canada it's
actually a surplus of more than forty
billion dollars
in any case the Americans are really the
ones who are making off like bandits in
this trade relationship all right but in
Mexico it's a bit different because even
correcting the numbers the u.s. still
gets the deficit in this relationship so
the question is what is the actual
number well wait for it approximately
drumroll please
0.25 percent of its GDP yes I'm sorry to
disappoint you it is really that little
in fact the deficit is actually smaller
than the one they have with China Japan
or Germany almost all American
industries export to Mexico more than
they import with the exception of
automobile
[Music]
so you can guess where the profits are
going to ends up but there is more it is
said that the main reason for the
companies moving their factories to
Mexico is because the wages are lower
but that's only half the truth and
certainly isn't the main reason what's
interesting about Mexico the car
companies is that Mexico has many more
free trade agreements with other
countries than the u.s. does and this
allows them to produce and sell their
cars in other markets like Brazil and
the European Union without tariffs which
saves them a lot of money about 700
million dollars a year and where are the
benefits of these operations going to
end up yes once again back in the pocket
of the United States of America just
like atoms with casinos the house always
wins
so thanks to Mexico car companies in the
USA are more competitive and to have
more profits while consumers in America
can buy much cheaper car
because of all of this Americans have
more money to go to the cinema to buy
clothes to change their smartphones more
often and take part in all that consumer
spending that we all love so much this
all makes the economic wheels spin
faster
[Music]
so it male probably seems to you that
yeah Mexico is actually pretty important
to the USA but imagine the other way
round almost 80% of Mexican exports ends
up in their northern neighbor so it's no
surprise that the threat of the end of
NAFTA has reminded many of the famous
quote attributed to war theory ideas to
go so far from God and so near the USA
that certain has been incredibly
positive for Mexico as a quick example
do you know which is the biggest
employer in Mexico
well that's Walmart unfortunately this
huge investment by US companies hasn't
actually given the growth to is expected
and for the reason for that we need to
look at responsibility inside Mexico
itself now the truth is the Mexican
politicians don't know how to take
advantage of this fantastic opportunity
to make Mexico more modern and more
competitive and as you know bad politics
equals bad results
[Music]
so does all of this mean that Mexico has
to kneel in front of Donald Trump well
certainly not
[Music]
Donald Trump is threatens Mexico with
high tariffs on their products if they
refuse to pay for the wall to be
specific Trump's administration has
threatened a 20 percent tariff increase
for starters well this would be illegal
there are rules in the World Trade
Organization that prevent this from
happening one of these is known as the
most favored nation which means that one
member of the WTO cannot discriminate
against another in fact this means that
the maximum tariff would be limited to 3
percent in the case that NAFTA were
abolished this would be a tax for
consumers and American companies and
wouldn't effects the trade between the
two nations but even if the US with the
approval of Congress were willing to
ignore international law Mexico has
enough resources to fight and try and
stop this first Mexico would be able to
take advantage of the influence of the
multinational corporations operating in
Mexico which could stand to lose
billions of dollars and this is not just
the influence of a few rich men we're
talking about all of these companies
workers and their shareholders as well
as millions of individual savers
throughout the United States and the
second reason well relations between
Mexico and the US aren't just commercial
immigration drug trafficking terrorism
these are just a few aspects of their
relationship if Trump attacks
economically
Mexico could fight back for example by
letting the u.s. drown in drugs and
immigration waves from countries all
across Latin America the fact is that
the u.s. and Mexico knew each other more
than it seems and Mexico is not in this
week of a position as Trump thinks
although the president of Mexico is
unpredictable it does look like he
understands this and the message from
his government is clear let's talk about
NAFTA we can renegotiate this treaty but
then all these other treaties we're also
going to be open to negotiation so this
is what we think is going to happen here
a visual politic and we'd love to know
what you think do you think Mexico
should defend itself tooth and nail even
with the risk of triggering a trade war
with the United States or do you think
the nation should be patient to let
things go and look for a solution
elsewhere let us know in the comments
below we do read them then we try to
reply when we can don't forget them we
thought our brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday so do not
subscribe and otherwise I'll see you in
the next video I think I'm going to win
the Mexican vote Mexico Mexico Mexico we
have a problem called Mexico I mean
Mexico's killing us Mexico's Colima
Mexico is disgusting Mexico exocomp
you're killing us Jeff
el hombre del headed a quinn i don't
care if i mispronounce it doesn't matter